Are there any programs on the rife that should not be used while healing from cancer?
I don't think everybody's ever asked me that before.
Oh no, I don't think so.
I mean, the only thing that I would say is that, you know, let's say you're dealing with
the throws of cancer and the cancer is very active and growing.
I would spend most of my time running my cancer program and not worry about my cold morbidities.
However, it can be true that my cold morbidities can be, you know, affecting my ability to
get better from cancer.
So you just kind of got to balance that out and see what's the most important thing for
you.
You know what, you'd be ready to program for, I don't know, you know, your glaucoma and,
you know, have you not be ready to get cancer programs or something like that, but so just
have a balance in that.
But there's nothing that you can't run.
So, insertively different infections and things like that can bring a person down who has cancer.
So you want to run infectious programs, if you got the crud like I have right now,
running the pneumonia blaster and the cold and flu programs and the different influenza programs
might be a wise thing to do.
So you just, you got to try to use your best sense of that, but there isn't anything that
you should not use while trying to heal cancer, no, there would be anything harmful in any way.